please welcome du liebe
I don't seem a bit weird with the hand
shape that we don't shake hands yes now
yeah you have a you have a lot of
tattoos yeah you have a word do you you
written on your hand
yeah that's patience yes why is that a
friendly reminder in my line of work I
always especially when I'm making music
like I always just want to get it out as
quick as possible and I want to put it
out there but I guess it's just a
reminder that patience is a virtue and
sometimes you have to wait for good
things to happen and yeah it's I've got
it on my hand you see so I never forget
it you always knew that this was what
you wanted
mm-hmm you wanted to end up here nope I
mean not here but but that was there
wasn't a plan B there was no plan B
exactly I I just you know I always
wanted to do music and music was very
such a big part of my life growing up
and my parents always listened to lots
of music at home and it was just you
know it's always that like I don't
really have like my earliest memory of
music cause it was always around and I
was always singing and I knew I wanted
to do music but it was only when I moved
to Kosovo at the age of 11 which is
where my parents are from that I
realized what born London to Kosovo at
the age of eleven because my parents
moved to London because of the war that
was happening in Kosovo and I guess you
know one one thing people have to
remember isn't people don't normally
leave their homes unless they really
have to so for my parents it was always
a massive dream of theirs to go back to
Kosovo and go back to their families and
live there and work there so when I was
11 we moved back to Kosovo which was
such an incredible experience and so
much fun and you know I'll be nian I
mean you just spoke the language right
yeah Albanian was my first language so I
spoke I've been Ian at home and then I
learnt English in school so I could
speak Albanian but when you go to school
there it's
completely different cuz you have to do
everything like you have to speak with
the right grammar and you have to start
learning science and biology and maths
and a completely different language and
alongside that the the the maths and the
sciences in general was so advanced in
comparison to what I was learning in
London so I really had to and because
kids start school a little bit later I
was like the youngest in my year so
there was a lot of adapting you know
although I could speak the language but
it was living in college before behind a
little bit
it took me you know it took me a couple
years while I was there to really get my
grades up up up to the point that on my
last year there I got A's and then I
left at fifteen you left for London
right yeah I went back to London so what
I wanted to say was was when I was
living in Kosovo I kind of I realized
that in order for me to be able to do
music and to pursue this career I had to
be in a place which for me you know I
felt like everything was happening and
that was London you know live my dream
and work really hard towards that which
makes me kind of sad about the current
political situation and the refugee
situation because it saddens me that
maybe younger generations won't have the
same opportunities that I had but how
was I mean how was that conversation
when you were as a fifteen year old you
moved back to Kosovo your parents wanted
to be there mhm
and you you're asking them if you could
move back alone 15 years oh well you
know my parents put a lot of trust in me
and they understood how much I wanted to
to perform and do music and it was kind
of on the basis that I stay in school
and they were like if you stay in school
then you can you know pursue music and
it took a little bit persuading but as
my dad likes to say it's very hard to
say no to me cuz I don't take no for an
answer
so where there happen I did things
happen while you had this life in London
this your own life in London did things
happen that you couldn't tell your
parents on the phone so when I got to
the part where I said and then I told my
parents I went to bed sometimes the
night continued with my friends but did
you ever end up in trouble or was it was
it like
safe I don't know what would you mean by
trouble
it depends what trouble means you were
on the right side of the law that said
that way for most of it yeah
no I'm taking I'm taking oh yeah no I
was I was a good kid watching so yeah
they probably are which is why I'm being
very careful with what I'm saying here
yeah I mean I only got told off by a
policeman once what happened that I hurt
my parents not listening I was it just
it was a really silly game but me and my
friends were basically decided to into a
massive bubble bath the bubbles are kind
of exploding out of the the bathtub and
a friend of mine was living in a very
like central area in London so he
decided to start throwing bubbles out of
our balcony to try and get rid of them
the water as well a little bit both and
we were much I mean I was 15 at the time
and it was it was all like fun and games
until we hit a policeman passing by
who then basically I think they were
just trying to scare us
but they they came up to the apartment
but called a couple more policemen to
come and tell us off and tell us we were
going to get a little letter sent and I
was terrified that my mom was gonna find
out she was living in Kosovo and she was
just like I thought she was gonna send
me back but she didn't find out luckily
so it was there it was it was she well
now it was very it was very silly you
describe your parent that's the
strongest love you know yes you know way
well I I guess my parents have been
through a lot and their love has
survived there a lot and they've been
through Wars literally you know they've
they've they've been so patient and
persistent and they've you know
sacrificed for us to have or feel like
we're not missing out on anything you
know I've seen them adapt to so many
different circumstances and and worked
are the best of their ability to be able
to be you know where they are and to try
and give us like the best education and
you know I don't know for us family is
everything and we're we're so close and
that's really a testament to their love
and their relationship and how they are
like with each other we have such me and
my siblings of such great role models
but with them as role models do you do
do you feel the pressure in your own
relationship it's it's gotta be as great
as as good as that as a um you know when
when I see my parents at least I know
that it's it's real you know and and
something like that exists so if
anything it's hopeful
[Applause]
I will give you given me that experience
and growing up with that family
you've write a lot about heartbreak yes
he's so many songs about heartbreak what
do you think that is sometimes it's the
easiest thing to kind of remember it was
kind of how someone or something made
you feel whereas on this album I feel
like I still have my forte which is
dance crying dance crying yeah explain
that it's songs about heartbreak yeah
but still your dancing yeah it's like a
celebration of vulnerability it's kind
of coming to the understanding that
being open about your feelings there's
strength in that and that it doesn't
always have to be all bad like you can
sing about stuff that is very heartfelt
and emotional but who says that you
can't dance to it and that's kind of my
favorite thing as always juxtaposition I
often wonder if if you were performing
if you were like an artist with just a
guitar or perhaps a male artist with a
guitar yeah the people would interpret
you different and your lyrics different
I think if I was a if I was a man people
will interpret everything differently I
don't think
[Applause]
I don't think everything would be kind
of looked under the looking-glass so
much but I think being a female artist
everything every little word you say or
everything you do kind of gets linked
and either your personal life or what's
going on or everything gets you know
dissected whereas if you were a male
artist with the guitar or by a piano
everyone's like yeah well done like this
dude he wrote everything it's it's
instantly genuine it's completely
different whereas I think we all have to
work you know as women we have to work a
little bit harder to be taken seriously
and that's a fact but I don't think
we're afraid of working harder because
it's something we've had to do our whole
life
[Applause]
you're a vengeful future nostalgia hmm
what about nostalgia now what can make
you nostalgic these days my childhood
influences in music which really were
which really was you know music that my
parents listened to that I've claimed as
my own influences and especially for
this album it was artists like
Jamiroquai and Moloko and prince and
blondie and you know that I feel like I
realized this is my music that's my
music well that's really cool too early
but we're gonna have a lot of music in
this program so thank you so much for
being with us tonight thank you ollie
pop okay hope you enjoyed the clip for
more interesting conversations please
hit subscribe
you